For this video, I’m going to show you how
to make an easy and reusable fruit-fly trap,
that’s surprisingly effective. And leaves
your kitchen, smelling lemony fresh, as well.
All you need for this kitchen creation, is
a small container with a lid, and a lemon.
Use a sharp knife to cut the end off the lemon,
then slice it in half, so you have a piece
that’s flat on the top, and flat on the
bottom.
Go ahead and squeeze a bit of the juice into
the container, to get the lemon scents flowing,
then simply plop the rest of the slice, inside.
Now finishing up is almost as simple, as adding
the lid.
It just needs to have a tiny hole punched
in it first.
So poke, or burn a hole just barely big enough
to let fruit flies in, but small enough, that
they’ll have a hard time, finding their
way back out.
With that done, simply snap the lid back onto
the container, and your reusable fruit-fly
trap is ready to get to work.
Make as many as you want, for as cheap as
you want, and put them, wherever you want.
For some reason, fruit flies really like lemons,
and most of them will find their way inside
the container, but won’t be in any hurry
to get back out.
When you’ve had enough of them, simply drip
a bit of water through the hole, and place
the container in the microwave on high heat,
for 15-30 seconds.
As the container cooks, the flies drop dead,
and a “lemony fresh” scent, fills the air instead.
The best part is, if you’ve got more flies
to catch, simply refresh your traps, and do
it again as many times as you want.
Well now you know how to make a simple kitchen
gadget, that filters out fruit fly challenges,
and freshens your air at the same time.
That’s it for now. If you liked this project,
perhaps you’ll like some of my others.
Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com